الفنانون الروس يرتدون الدونتيل الشفاف
ويتباهون بثرواتهم في احتفال شبه عار اثار
جدلا كبيرا بسبب ما اعتبره البعض تعارضا
مع القيم المحافظه
للبلاد انا غاضبه اذا قرروا الاحتفال
فليفعل ذلك في
الخفاء يجب ان يخجلوا من اولئك الذين
يقاتلون من اجلنا اقامه هذه الحفله في هذا
التوقيت كانت فكره غبيه كان بالامكان
اخفاء
الامر يايت مغني الراب فازيو الذي حضر
الامسيه شبه عار عقب بالسجن لمده 15 يوما
بتهمه دعم المثليه المغني فيليب كيركوروف
الذي تم تكريمه سابقا من قبل الرئيس بوتين
عبر عن ندمه على المشاركه في هذا
الحفل في هذه الاوقات الصعبه وفي هذه
الاوقات البطوليه التي تمر بها روسيا ما
كان ينبغي على فنان
التور في مثل هذا النو من
الاحداث غضب المواطنين الروس كان في
الاساس ضد منظمه الامسيه المؤثره انستاسيا
ايلفا وقد تم رفع دعوه قضائيه جماعيه ضدها
تطالبها بدفع 10 ملايين يورو لمنظمه تدعم
الحرب على
اوكرانيا يقولون ان روسيا بلد متسامح اذا
كان هذا صحيحا اق
ان اعتذر من
شعبي انا اسفه بصدق لكل من عان بسبب هذا
الحفل الكريملين امتنع من جانبه عن
الادلاء باي تعليق لكن هذه القضيه اعادت
الى الاذهان التحول المحافظه في روسيا
والذي برز في السنوات الاخيره بسبب السراع
في
اوكرانيا